[Music]
foreign
[Music]
times
so 10 was just a little bit scared
because seven eight nine get it oh hello
welcome to Story Time my name is Eddie
and this is big Ted we're gonna read you
a story I wonder what the story will be
about today big Ted
oh did you hear that that was the sound
of the magic story drawer
[Music]
it's inside
it's a rocket ship
and the story today is called
[Music]
elephant
there's an elephant with a long trunk
a rocket blasting off and a moon
I wonder if this story has something to
do with space
let's find out
and The Story Goes Like This
one ordinary Monday at 9 00 a.m
precisely Stella walked into space
command
hello she said I'd like to become an
astronaut
ah she's called Stella and is an
elephant
get it fixed head skeleton
[Music]
the man stopped clacking on his keyboard
and looked up split
but you're an elephant said the man I am
said Stella holding out her application
but we've never had an elephant
astronaut before said the man
I know said Stella I would be the first
I'm sorry said the man but I don't think
we can let an elephant be an astronaut
imagine what would happen
we'd have all sorts of animals applying
for approval
but you have sent some animals to space
said Stella the man nodded
then why not an elephant asked Stella
look at all the pictures of astronauts
on the wall
I can see some monkeys
[Music]
and dogs
can you make a dog noise too
what about an elephant noise
I'm sorry said the man
but the other animals were smaller we
don't make spacesuits in your size or
shape unless you can find a spacesuit to
fit you I can't approve your application
Stella is reading a book called
do-it-yourself spacesuits so Stella
measured
and stitched and tinkered
until finally it was ready
now can I be an astronaut asked Stella
I'm sorry said the man but you need to
complete basic training and we're just
not set up to train elephants you're too
big you'd break all our equipment
unless you can find training somewhere
else
I can't approve your application
so Stella found teachers and she studied
look Stella is doing maths
I love maths
do you like to count numbers too
I could talk about maths all day but
let's get back to Stella's training
Stella is at King's jungle gym
and strengthened
and practiced and prepared
until finally she was ready
now can I be an astronaut asked Stella
I'm sorry said the man blood our Rockets
aren't built to lift elephants you're
too heavy besides you wouldn't even fit
through the door
unless you can find another rocket
can't approve your application
find another rocket
how will Stella find another rocket
can you guess
so Stella sketched and tested
and assembled
until finally it was ready
now can I be an astronaut asked Stella
I'm sorry said the man but you need a
crew and unfortunately none of our
astronauts want to fly with an elephant
they say it's bad luck they say it's too
dangerous
they say something's bound to go wrong
unless you can find a crew I can't
approve your application
Stella isn't having much luck is she
where will Stella find a crew
so Stella gathered her friends and
together they studied and strengthened
and practiced and prepared until finally
they were all ready
a tiger
penguin an octopus and a sloth Stella
has great friends
I have a crew said Stella now can we be
astronauts
the man didn't know what to do well
um he said
I'll get my manager
do you know what a manager is
do you know big Ted
someone who is in charge yes that's
right
the man's manager didn't know what to do
so he went and got his manager
the man's manager's manager didn't know
either so he went and got his manager on
and on this web until they ran out of
managers
so they asked the big boss of space
command the big boss and all the
managers sat at a long table to have a
long talk about the elephant in the room
why wouldn't they approve my application
don't Stella I've trained for this I
have a suit a rocket and a crew they
have to let me be an astronaut they have
to
[Music]
they have to right big Ted
then Stella realized that actually they
didn't have to
she didn't need their approval
she had everything she needed already
we are go for launch
e minus ten
nine eight
seven
six
five four
three two one ignition
we have liftoff
whoosh there goes the rocket blasting
through the sky and into space
Stella with all her friends in their
spacesuits
floating in space and looking down on
Earth
Stella and her wonderful crew in the
state elephant Aerospace Hall of
astronauts
and that's the end of the story
well done Stella and crew your hard work
certainly paid off
would you like to travel to space
[Music]
what about you big Ted maybe one day
you'll blast off into space with your
friends
it's time for us to go now
bye from big Ted
and buy from me bye
now the reason why is 789 was because
she wanted three Square meals a day get
it it's really bad I know I'm sorry
foreign